what if a dramatic surge of climate
change melted all the Earth's ice
overnight would you wake up to find
yourself drowning underwater what most
of your country be submerged how would
you enjoy slowly choking to death this
is what if and here's what would happen
if all the world's ice melted ever
watched an ice cube melt in a glass of
water that's filled to the brim how does
it change the water level the truth is
it doesn't above or below the water line
a melted ice cube replaces exactly the
same volume of water now let's add salt
to the mix in the case of a 1 cubic inch
ice cube the water level in the glass
will rise by point zero three cubic
inches that rise is displaced salt water
it's an increase in volume of nearly
three percent fairly small amount isn't
it but what if you apply this to the
glaciers and floating sea ice five point
eight million square miles of our planet
is covered with ice if all of it were to
melt overnight the global sea level
would rise approximately 230 feet that's
enough to cover London's Tower Bridge
all seven continents would be partially
underwater
there'd be no Miami and no London the
coast of Australia would be washed out
together with eighty percent of its
residents so would Venice and the
Netherlands things wouldn't be that bad
for Africa but with the extreme heat
waves that follow most of the continent
would be uninhabitable think floods
would wash out humanity entirely well
not all of it but whoever's left will
have plenty of dangers to deal with all
that melted ice would release carbon
dioxide into the air ice needs high co2
concentrations to melt in the first
place given that oxygen content in the
atmosphere would remain the same you
would slowly start to choke from
breathing the air
you'd have very little time to
acclimatize to the new world ocean
currents would change their direction
affecting sea life with no time to
evolve to such extreme changes sea
creatures and polar animals would face
massive extinction the ones still alive
would have to leave their homes and find
a better place to live this would result
in a decrease of human food supply a
change in sea current would also mean
dramatic weather changes
heavy rains would hit the desert and
areas with significant rainfall would
dry out this would devastate agriculture
and cause a global famine wind patterns
would change too with no ice to reflect
the sun's rays the Sun would draw more
moisture from the oceans making more
clouds in the sky the clouds would
gather first near the mountain areas and
eventually rainfall would flood them
oceanic hurricanes would occur more
often causing even more floods even the
smallest earthquake off the coast could
devastate nearby regions with a massive
tsunami all of this would force a global
migration that governments would not be
able to deal with the world as we know
it would collapse luckily all the ice
can't melt overnight but it is melting
even the oldest ice core that has been
storing information about the Earth's
climate for one and a half million years
if we keep adding fuel to the climate
change fire in five thousand years the
earth will be ice-free
[Music]
you